it's all about like contribution like  what are you giving back in service how  are you empowering other people i just  feel like so lucky like i can't believe  i get to do this  and there's a feeling that you get when  you know like  i'm trying to do good even if i'm not  succeeding necessarily like the  intention is there i'm not saying people  should become podcasters but  there has to be something that you  gravitate towards when you cultivate  that curiosity  that over time can develop into  something that is  both a pursuit that nourishes you but  also nourishes others david goggins  would tell you that  that motivation and inspiration are  fleeting they're not sustainable sources  of energy like mike fremont the  centenarian says make your life about  service and that's going to look  different for every single person but  you know there's something really  beautiful and indelibly true about that